hey what's up mrs. John Delaney with
Ramsey Network hope you're doing well
hope you're staying safe and being smart
and being kind today we are continuing
our conversation about how to help
somebody with anxiety that you love in
the moment right now this series was
inspired by an email from an awesome
husband named Chris who wrote in and
said he wanted to be a fire extinguisher
for his wife's anxiety he wanted to
learn how to better support her as he's
watching the woman he loves
grind herself down through
accomplishment work trying to be a
perfect mom perfect wife perfect
domestic house peace keeper all of it
and he just wants to learn how to love
her better so if you haven't watched the
videos everything you know about anxiety
is wrong 1 2 & 3 the link is below right
here watch those videos because in those
videos I talk about anxiety is just a
fire alarm it's just a signal that your
kitchen is on fire that your house is on
fire that the world you've created for
yourself or the world you've been thrown
into by somebody else is on fire it's
just a signal so in part 1 of this video
I told Chris skin-on-skin contact
looking her in the eyes connecting with
his wife willing to make a plan with her
every week for a week on week on a week
and offering to go to counseling with
her so that he could learn ways that he
could become better not ways he could
fix her but ways he could become a
better more effective husband were some
ways that he could support wife and so
today I want to talk about why I told
him to do that why are those things
important to do when we're looking at
the person we love just running around
trying to solve everything and be
everything and accomplish everything
when our anxiety alarms go off our
prefrontal cortex unhooks it unhooks and
our alarm system takes over fight flight
freeze run look out hit somebody that
thing takes over in our brains trade
accuracy for speed and what that means
is we run through our house looking for
places where we don't belong looking for
the threats and I'm just gonna
accomplish accomplish and go and go and
get and get
and when and we miss the person who
sitting there saying hey I love you
we missed the kid who say hey mom can we
just sit down and hang out hey Dad
you just looked me in the eye and come
play Legos with me we miss that because
we're just going going going
skin-on-skin contact brings your
prefrontal cortex back online in crisis
world we used to do this we'd go into a
house where someone had just been shot
and killed or someone had just lost a
loved one or someone had just been in a
bad wreck and I would see my partner
from across the room and they would just
say this and what that meant was we need
to get this person from fully limbic to
prefrontal cortex we need to get them
from there's danger here there's danger
here too there was danger but you're
safe right now and that's what we're
trying to do with skin on skin contact
with connection with looking somebody in
the eye holding their hand and saying
how is today how was today planning
every week is about settling down that
amygdala that what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen I don't know but this week
we've got a plan today we've got a plan
in the last video I said people are not
machines they don't break they adapt
they move they wiggle around people are
not puzzles to solve they're not
problems to achieve they're people to be
with and so by asking hey can I go to
therapy with you so I can learn some
better tools for me so that I can
support you better number one that
brings somebody back online that brings
them peace I've got support
I'm anchored into something and so I may
feel like I'm swaying in the wind but
I'm anchored we live in a culture that
tells us I am my own self I am
responsible for me I can pull myself up
by my own bootstraps and solve all of my
problems by myself that is a lie we Co
regulate our emotions our body is always
scanning for how are you how are we how
are we doing think about when a mom hugs
a baby and holds our close to her chest
their heart rates sync up their breath
cycles sync up grown up to the same
thing when someone you love is anxious
and exhausted and accomplishing and
spinning and you take out the trash and
so they come up with something else
focus on connecting focus on being still
focus on doing your part of the
co-regulation
breathing deeply looking him in the eye
touching him on the hands asking them
how can I serve you today
what's your picture of what today is
going to look like can I come with you
to learn some more tools so that I can
be better for you when you begin to
connect in this way the final part is to
hold somebody accountable we say this is
what today's picture was gonna look like
and I know you're anxious and I know
you're feeling jumpy but watching more
Netflix isn't gonna help we said we're
gonna take three walks this week let's
go let's go take a walk because I love
you enough to hold you accountable
that's not shaming you that's not piling
on that's not adding to that's just
accountability and when you co-create a
plan together somebody who loved
somebody hold them accountable that's
what relationships are for in the next
video we're gonna talk about how to
fireproof your kitchen because we're
going to continue just to beat this
analogy completely to death how do you
co-create a world with your kids with
your partner with your family that helps
everybody be less anxious more present
more together and gives them an
opportunity to overtime
function with less fire alarms going off
everywhere this is dr. John Delaney with
Ramsey Network leave all of the
Internet's follow subscribes oh call
this deloading have a good week